many of us spend more time on social
media than we probably should but for
some users sites like Facebook Twitter
and yes Instagram
can become a troubling obsession causing
them to lose touch with reality
Madhavi Lal takes us to a place where
young people are getting help for their
social media addiction I was strung with
severe depression and anxiety 17 year
old David Mayer from Ohio says he fell
constant pressure from his parents to be
perfect overwhelmed he started using
drugs he also got lost online for up to
four hours a day I felt like with all of
my posts I would create this false
character of who I was what I thought
was the perfect version of myself what I
wanted to be which is this young funny
attractive guy and obviously I was kind
of neglecting the fact that I did have a
lot of sadness within me and a lot of
loneliness David became withdrawn and
stopped talking to his parents until
they took matters into their own hands I
got woken up 4:00 a.m. just two guys
with my bags packed and I was pretty
frightened at first but I mean did you
know these guys know my parents had
hired them to take me here they forced
David into the paradigm Malibu rehab
facility for 30 days to treat his social
media addiction no cell phones or
internet surfing allowed fifty percent
of teens say they feel addicted to their
mobile devices and studies show teens
who spend more time on social media are
more likely to report mental health
issues than those who spend less time on
the sites and sent my room for days at a
time and just kind of be there and I had
nothing else to do is that very it's
kind of curl up and go on social media
seventeen-year-old Arizona native
Caitlin Walker is also seeking treatment
at paradigm Kaitlyn says things began
spiraling out of control when her
parents marriage hit a rough patch she
turned to social media for comfort but
instead became the target of online
bullying like I literally had pictures
of my camera love people like bullying
me and I kept it why I don't know it was
just kind of like confirmation that I
wasn't good enough they
you know that Instagram and Twitter and
Facebook are causing you all this pain
why do you keep going back to it then
it's hard to detach and realize that
it's a really negative part of your life
paradigm says it's program which
includes therapy and reconnecting with
the outdoors has an 80% success rate it
can cost upwards of 50,000 dollars but
some insurance companies do help cover
the expense after 30 days Caitlin isn't
ready to delete her profiles but she's
now learned you have the power to block
someone or delete them or not look at it
and I think when I was in that situation
I didn't feel like I had the power to do
that David now fills his time playing
basketball and reading his program might
be over but his journey is just
beginning
I plan on deleting my Twitter deleting
my snapchat I know now that I'm not
going to create this this false
character I just you know give more time
for myself media via CBS News Malibu
California it's tough out there because
a lot of mental health professionals
aren't quite there but anxious to call
this a true addiction so it's it needs
more study and certainly a lot of the
people out there suffering from it need
help yeah there are kids who really need
help